a partir de mañana deja de funcionar la
aplicación de seguimiento personal que
durante casi tres años ha sido uno de
los principales pilares de la política
cero covid esa aplicación gracias a la
geolocalización del móvil permitía
registrar los itinerarios de la
población de forma que se se había
estado en una zona de medio o alto
riesgo se limitaban o prohibían sus
desplazamientos el anuncio de hoy supone
el último clavo en la tumba de la
política cero covid la semana pasada ya
se levantó la obligación de presentar en
la entrada de la mayoría de edificios
públicos un resultado negativo del test
realizado en los últimos tres días a
partir de ahora solo es obligatorio en
hospitales y colegios el fin de la
xerocovic explica que algunas ciudades
estén sufriendo brotes sin precedentes y
totalmente descontrolados es el caso de
Pekín las cifras oficiales hablan de un
millar de contagios diarios pero al no
haber test No hay forma de saber cuál es
la magnitud del brote popularizado un
chiste aquí si no tienes a 10 amigos con
covid es que no tienes amigos el fin del
acercó bien no ha traído ningún júbilo
de hecho la ciudad está bastante más
alicaída ahora que Durante los encierros
porque la gente tiene miedo y los bares
restaurantes y supermercados están semi
vacíos además algunos hospitales están
ya saturados y muchas farmacias han
agotado las existencias de medicinas
contra la fiebre todo el mundo quiere
prepararse ante un invierno muy duro